[Music]
so for those of you who are here to hear
about the great economy what I want to
do is to give you a sense firstly um how
their ideas have changed the world now
of course I don't want to say that these
are only economic ideas that have
changed the world but rather it is what
economics has played a part in reshaping
the society in which we live which is
essentially how I approach the book
which is if you look back and look at
the extraordinary number of changes that
have affected our society since the
Industrial Revolution 250 years ago how
we got here and the lessons that history
holds the ideas that have changed our
lives those are worth looking at as we
face our current challenges and think
about really Mark Twain's quote which is
history doesn't repeat itself but it
often rhymes and so I'm going to start
off with some of those ideas have
changed the world and then through the
course of the next half hour go through
the people behind those ideas so the
great thinkers of our time the of the
earlier vintage and how their ideas
maybe could just maybe help us with some
of our challenges today so I'm going to
focus on two really two main ideas the
first one is the idea that has changed
the world was the end of protectionism
and this is in 1846 when the corn laws
were repealed now you remember in 1846
now nobody remembers 1846 but up until
that point mercantilism was the belief
of the day that was the idea that
governs the day which is countries
should run trade surpluses now even
better if you could go and find some
gold and silver
hope with much great surplus then that's
really mercantilism but what changed was
globalization so Britain in 1846
repealed the protectionist legislation
the corn loss which was protecting the
profits of landowners around agriculture
output and instead made globe made
Britain a global internationally focused
economy so globalisation made Britain
the world's biggest trader globalization
enhanced the world's first industrial
nation and gave it a global standing but
that was an idea that had been argued by
classical economists and it wasn't until
Sir Robert Peel the prime minister
changed his mind and agreed with the
economists that the Corn Laws were
repealed and an era of prosperity in the
late Victorian period began and by the
way shortly after the repeal the Corn
Laws Sir Robert Peel lost his
Premiership and then his party was out
in the wilderness for a generation but
the Corn Laws got repealed and the
second big idea that changed the world
is the welfare state so what happened
with the panic of 1873 was a US
financial crisis that spread across the
Atlantic and that was when unemployment
first appeared in the dictionary because
it triggered the first Great Depression
of the nineteenth century known as the
long depression that also was when trade
unionism rose and that was when Marx
made his ideas known and by the early
part of the 20th century 60% of the
world lived in either communist or
socialist regimes so it became a battle
between capitalism and communism it
became a battle between democracy and
the communist regimes which existed then
so think about the Bolshevik Revolution
in 1917 the rise of the Soviet Union
and that caused the economists of the
day to rethink capitalism so capitalism
wasn't working for everyone and this is
when you started to have the late
Victorian say well actually a capitalist
system needs to be revised to suit what
the 20th century needed so the late
Victorians believed in helping the
deserving poor and the arguments who
really made then about how you can
introduce a welfare element into
capitalism and that began to win hearts
and minds and this was where really when
the welfare state the NHS in this
country in continental Europe in the
United States changed the capitalism of
Adam Smith and made it welfare state
capitalism and after World War two it
looked like the tide was beginning to
turn but it wasn't until the fall of the
Berlin Wall and the disintegration of
the Soviet Union in the late 1980s that
really this battle between democracy and
communism between capitalism
well Thursday capitalism this new form
took precedence over the appeal of the
Communists and the socialist regimes of
course we know fast forward to the
present day we've had another American
financial crisis that has spread across
the world and we are now also at a time
when capitalism needs rethinking there's
again a backlash against globalization
the consensus that was forged after the
end of the Cold War seems no longer to
be there so we are now in the 21st
century at the same point about
rethinking the economic system that
needs to be revised to work for all of
us in the 21st century and that's really
the motivation for writing this book for
me which is to learn these lessons of
history and that you tackle the big
issues of today and think about the ways
in which we can change our current
market based economy to work better more
equitably and more focused on the
of growth so looking back to history the
great economist whose ideas I'm gonna
draw on are the ones that did think
about the big questions of the day the
great economists have an earlier vintage
many of them were not economists at all
there were philosophers and so I'll go
through them briefly because I think to
understand ideas we really must
understand the people the person behind
those ideas so these are the ones that I
cover and this is a ruff-ruff mapping as
to where they sit so the Adam Smith
David Ricardo they're sort of more
classical and neoclassical economists
sit here so they believe in the market
I'm driving the economy but they believe
the state has a role in ensuring that
the market is competitive so that's
different then more free market
economists like Friedrich Hayek who is
the motivation behind Thatcherism as
well as the Reagan Revolution in the
1980s and then and by contrast on the
other side is Karl Marx who believed
that the capitalist system will
inevitably lead to a demand for more
egalitarian system and that's the
communist system where the state decides
everything but in between you also have
John Maynard Keynes he sits between the
sort of state and market because Maynard
Keynes convinced us all in the 1930s the
Keynesian revolution that the state
could intervene in the economy in fact
the state had to intervene in the
economy and before waiting for the
long-run as the classical economists
believed when everything would be sorted
out he'll be back in equilibrium and
Kings famously said we're all dead in
the long run and then his disciple who
I'm also going to talk about is Joan
Robinson now Joan Robinson was a
Keynesian disciple in the 1930s where
she made her name the reason I'm going
to talk about her is because her theory
of monopsony helps us to explain our
current challenge with low
ages yr wages so low so she writes about
it in the 1930s she started off the
1930s as the wife of a Cambridge Don by
the end of the 1930s she was the most
prominent female economist a great
economist by the way she was one of the
five Cambridge economist within Keynes's
inner circle and trusted to review the
general theory
she was also married to one of the other
ones and having an affair with another
one so I like to think she had a casting
vote on the general theory but I've
moved her slightly towards the state end
because later her career she disavowed
Keynesianism and she began to admire
communist regimes so in her lectures at
Cambridge she would turn up in
Vietnamese peasant outfit so I sort of
moved her more towards the Marx end and
then finally Douglas North a great
economist that I write about so Douglas
north is the person whose ideas
introduce the importance of institutions
into economics for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you